hey guys and welcome to the return of
one of my oldest video series and that
is uh well kind of a weekly flipping
series now I initially uh dropped it
four months ago mainly just because I
was burnt out I wanted to do some other
content and I just felt like I had too
many uh videos on the Go at once so
another reason is because I was
sustaining the account with bonds so I
kind of felt obligated to play the
account to find items every single day
or else I just be kind of losing money
on membership this time around I'm going
to be paying for the membership uh with
just regular money and I'll leave the
in-game uh gains to be not meddled with
so I think my goal is going to be
getting one bill on this flipping
account uh I realized my initial goal
when I first made the series was just
100 Mil but you'll see after this uh
episode that really getting to under
Mill won't take very long so I don't
really think that that's a long-term
goal I think a bill is still actually
kind of reasonable now you might be
asking what about your road to one bill
account and honestly I'm just thinking
of renaming that because that has never
been really the goal and it's kind of my
own fault uh but it's never been it's
just a progress account honestly
probably just going to name it what it
is maybe come up with another catchy
name but just kind of shift the whole
goal of getting a bill to this account
because it makes a lot more sense and
then I don't have two overlapping titles
kind of thing anyway I hope you guys are
excited if you are definitely leave the
video a like uh so I know and uh let's
get started uh so what we're going to
start off by doing is trying to buy a
couple of the Dragon full Helms now with
the new update those have started to uh
rise up in price CU they're getting
removed from the drop table for uh the
brutal black dragons uh so yeah we'll
we'll put an offering for two of those
hopefully they don't drop down cuz that
would be a little unfortunate uh next up
we're looking at the zenite bracelet uh
not a very heavily traded item but we'll
give it a try uh we're going to try
buying it for about 10 mil which looks
about good and we'll do uh two of those
for now we're going to stick to some
slow items and last up with the rest of
our money I'm looking at the zamra pages
uh two I believe which actually have a
60 or 80k margin uh so that's actually
pretty good 655 to like 700 or something
uh for the price isn't bad and we'll
just do the buy limit uh which is oh
sorry we only have enough for three so
we'll do that and we'll come back with
hopefully some of these slow sales being
completed so I ended up not going with
the Dragon full mainly because the price
was uh just going up and down way too
much so we ended up buying the Eternal
crystals instead which we're still
waiting to sell off uh the zenite
necklaces ended up making
423k on each so about 850k in total
which is really good and the total made
about 135k off these amra Pages which is
still pretty uh respectable so next up
I'm thinking of buying the anku legs uh
it looks like on GE tracker it is about
837k uh margin which is amazing again
the GE tracker is a sponsor of mine so
if you want to go check them out there
will be a link in the description it's
very useful for items like this they're
much slower cuz it'll give a lot more
accurate prices so especially for items
like this G tracker is extremely useful
so we'll put an offer in for one anku
legs for now and once again I'm going to
go ahead with the zamak page two or a
zamak page at least and we'll go maybe
for 12 is a really awkward amount yeah
let's do 15 we might as well uh that's
three times the buying limit but we will
be at work all day so it's not a huge
deal and last up we're thinking of going
with the Den's ballor uh looks like 150
200k margin uh isn't as good as some of
the other items but we'll give it a try
and it kind of fits our cash amount
perfectly cuz we'll do two ah no we
can't that's unfortunate we'll go for
one I guess and the last step I guess
we're going to do the magic Stone it's
not an item that I end up buying that
much uh even though it does tend to have
a very good margin but there is a shop
you can go ahead and buy this from
anyway so often times you won't H get
people selling it to you but whatever
we'll give it a try for about 956k each
and hopefully we'll get a 50k margin on
that okay so unfortunately a lot of our
offers didn't end up buying at all uh
the most uh profitable thing that
actually did come through is the uh
Turnal Crystal uh which we ended with
getting a 200k margin on pretty well and
giv us about 582k in total the den
ballor didn't end up selling off yet uh
so hopefully we'll kind of break even on
that now another item that has been
affected recently by um an update is the
dragon Harpoon which I believe has hit
rock bottom is my guess so we're going
to go ahead and buy some of these and
hopefully we can profit off them nicely
uh so I think they're going to raise up
hopefully 500k to a mill uh cuz they
have reached their bottom point I'm
assuming uh so we're going to try buying
them for 8230
and uh we're going to go ahead and buy
maybe three or four of these all right
we ended up blowing her down just a
little bit just to be extra safe and
we'll go for five and uh that's going to
be pretty much it that's all our money
so unfortunately I should have held on
to my uh dragon harpoons a little bit
longer I only made about
120k per Harpoon so about 630k in total
which isn't bad but again I should have
held on a bit longer uh the den ball
work we just broke even on so that's not
a huge deal and the magic Stones I got
about 100 profit off of okay so next up
we're looking at the Mystic steam staff
which is a fairly cheap item with a 60k
margin on it right now uh so we'll go
ahead and buy maybe 10 of these guys cuz
they're not really not too expensive the
items at this price tend to have a much
better uh ratio you're getting back so
we'll go ahead and do 10 uh next up
we're looking at the armadel page two
again another page which looks like it
has about a 70 or 80k mergin on it uh
which is excellent so we'll go ahead and
maybe do 10 of those as well going to
have to hit the Buy on this one I
believe TS good next up another
mid-price item is the holy wraps which
looks like we could buy maybe around
800k and sell for maybe 900 even a m
possibly uh cuz they don't trade enough
so I think the margin could stretch to
200k I but we'll put them in for 801 and
I'll maybe do eight of these which I
think might be the limit and with the
rest of our money I think I'm going to
dump it into the infinity hat this item
tends to have a pretty good margin on it
pretty consistently and the item the
price kind of switches back and forth
quite a bit uh so we'll probably dump
the rest of our money into this cuz it's
about 3,410 of that would actually be
pretty much our entire cash tack so
we'll do 10 and call it a day all right
this is very successful all four flips
uh came through very nicely uh we'll
start with the uh Mystic steam staff
which was the worst uh 53k margin and
160k in total uh the armal page two I
came in with 106k on each page which is
awesome a 530k profit in total there
awesome holy wraps had a
174k margin on each one giv Us 870k in
total on that and the infinity hats gave
us 121k margin but we got eight of them
so
968 in total that's a 2.5 mil profit off
of all those items so uh while we didn't
end up buying too many of the staffs
earlier I think I'm going to go ahead
and buy some more of the Mystic steam
staffs uh G tracker just released their
new beta graph so we'll give that a try
um okay we'll buy him for 455 and
hopefully sell them for 600 that would
be a little too much possibly but we'll
give it a try all right so we're going
to put them in for 456 and we'll go try
10 of them again even though they didn't
come through so quickly next up we're
looking at the zamorakian spear uh which
has an okay mergin on it and would come
through very quickly so maybe we'll give
it a try Zing spear buy up for roughly
around 6.6 mil all right we're going to
put in for
6691 and uh we're going to I guess dump
most of our money in here we'll have to
reduce it one more and do seven and last
up the trusty Darkness set has always
provided some very good flips and uh
today is no different we're going to do
the robe uh bottom of darkness which is
a nice cheap item to do and can
sometimes have 100K margins on it
sometimes and we're just going to do 10
of them for about 295 and hopefully sell
it for maybe 380 or something like that
okay so I ended up switching out the Zam
ring spear for the Eternal Gem and it's
a good thing I did because we got an
insane margin on the Eternal gem both
310k on each one we sold them for a
couple different prices uh but overall
we got 310k given us about 2.2 mil in
profit off the item which is awesome the
other items were kind of worthless we
got a little bit on the RO bottom of
Darkness but um everything else was just
a break even but the Eternal gem ended
up giving it such a good profit this is
still a good flip okay so next up we're
going to try the infinity hat once again
it worked so well last time why not do
it again 3560 into
3750 uh that could be roughly a 200k
profit uh which seems pretty good to me
so we'll go put another offer in for the
infinity hat 3565 sounds good and we're
going to do uh maybe we'll just do four
or five of them and save some money for
some other flips okay next up we're
going to do the Eternal gem again we we
have to give it another try that was
just such a good flip uh we're going to
put him in for a little even cheaper
this time for about
5931 and we're going to do and let's do
four sounds good to me uh another 15 mil
to use last up we have the obsidian
helmet uh which looks pretty profitable
uh there's a huge gap that's just opened
up in the last uh I could have phrased
that a little better anyway there's a
good margin on it all right so we ended
up ditching the infinity hat because it
did not come through instead I ended up
flipping an Arcane prayer scroll only
about a 150k profit on that so nothing
too great but the Eternal gem once again
came in huge with a 360k mergin and we
got four of them so that's about 1.4 mil
in profit there and I think that's where
we're going to end up for today guys
after we claim all the items we'll be it
at about 59 mil which is a 9 mil profit
which I think is pretty good for the
first episode uh so if you did enjoy the
video please remember to leave it a like
uh so I can know well how much you guys
are enjoying the series so thanks for
watching guys and I will see you you
guys uh next time
[Music]